ça fait un mois que l'excès mosquée
était confiné dans son appartement dans
la région de Toula en Russie placé en
détention à domicile et surtout privé de
voir et de communiquer avec sa propre
fille Masha qui l'élève seule et sans
histoire depuis qu'elle est toute petite
[Musique]
de 13 ans n'a pas été vu depuis que
cette vidéo a été tournée le premier
mars quand la police est venue arrêter
son père à la maison et juste avant
qu'elle soit placée dans un orphelinat
le temps que son papa soit traduit en
justice pas plus tard que hier il
comparaissait pour plaider son innocence
mais tout a commencé en avril dernier
quand sa fille a dessiné se croquis
pendant un cours d'art à l'école on peut
lire non à la guerre et gloire à
l'Ukraine la direction aussitôt contacté
le Facebook et depuis le père est sous
enquête les services sociaux enquêtes
aussi parallèlement pour lui enlever la
garde de sa fille
vous comprenez ce qui est en jeu
l'orphelinat pour sa fille 17 femme
venue le soutenir en course matin oui
mais il mérite d'être puni parce qu'il a
violé la loi lui a répondu 7 militants
progaire juste avant que le verdict ne
soit prononcé
alexis a été jugé coupable et condamné à
deux ans de détention dans une colonie
de travail
n'était pas là pour la sentence il s'est
enfui la nuit dernière à annoncé à la
surprise générale la porte-parole du
tribunal sous les applaudissements de
ces supporters
son avocat sous le choc parce qu'il
ignore encore ce soir où se trouve son
client
2 ans de prison pour exprimer une
opinion setorible de cette conseillère
municipale qui accuse les autorités de
s'acharner sur leur cas cette affaire
est la dernière d'une série de jugements
ou d'accusation porte et contre des
Russes qui s'opposent publiquement à la
guerre et le cas de la famille moscalève
a pour but d'intimider tous les
opposants par la destruction de leur
famille à déclaré l'OMG mémorial sur sa
page Facebook
l'avocat du père nous a confié plus tard
quand nous l'avons finalement joué au
téléphone qu'il n'a jamais rien vu de
tel et se demande sincèrement ce qui a
bien pu lui arriver il s'inquiète pour
sa sécurité il est aussi tenté de voir
la petite au centre d'accueil mais on ne
l'a pas laissé lui parler
des dessins qu'elle aurait préparé un
petit message
tout simple papa tu es mon héros ici
Tamara Alteresco Radio-Canada Montréal